NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Good morning.
I'm Natalie.
I would like to invite
up some of my new friends
and some old friends
to the stage.
Will our panelists
please come on up?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I've got to take my phone and
Chapstick and everything else
that you shove in
your pockets out.
All right, so like
I said, I'm Natalie.
My core role here at
Google is as our Women
in Technology Advocate.
Little bit about myself is Megan
Smith is a friend and mentor,
and back in 2013, I was working
on Women Techmakers Makers
is a 20% Project with my friend
Stephanie Liu, who's here.
And basically I
was going to I/O,
and Women Techmakers
would really only
happen the night
before Google I/O.
It was a way for us to
galvanize and create community
prior to our big
technical conference.
Basically, I was like,
man, this can really
happen more than once a year.
And so I thought how can
we make this something that
scales around the world
and happens all the time?
So I went to Megan, and
I was like, Megan, I want
this to be my full-time job.
And so she went to
Hiroshi, she went Sundar,
and those gentlemen said,
yes, we will absolutely
make this her full-time job.
So I'm lucky enough that I got
to take my passion project,
my 20%, into a full-time job.
And so now at Google
I create a program
that helps to provide
visibility, community,
and resources for
women around the world.
And I'm incredibly
thankful for my job.
And I'm sure these other women
also have incredible jobs
that they want to tell
you a little bit about.
So we're going to
go down the line.
I'm going to have our awesome
panelists say their name
and a little bit
about themselves,
and also what
they're solving for.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: So, hi.
I'm Kimberly, and I'm a
Mechanical Engineer here
at Google.
I work on the
self-driving car project,
and I am Solving for
X, of course, but apart
from that I'm really passionate
about the work we're doing
with the self-driving car.
I really feel like
it's going to change
our world for the better.
For me personally, I have
two aging grandmothers
that really can't
drive at night anymore,
and I really believe
that the self-driving car
is going to give
them back mobility
and independence that they
are losing as they age.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
NAHID ALAM: Hi, how you doing?
I'm Nahid, I'm a
founder at Lighthouse.
We make voice control solutions
for your daily devices,
home devices.
So my background is in
hardware and electronics,
and I love building
tangible, physical things,
so my goal is to basically make
an everyday object work for you
so that you don't spend
time in daily chores.
KATE STIRR: Hi, my
name is Kate Stirr,
and I'm an Artist and
Prototyper at The Exploratorium.
I work in both
hardware prototyping
and educational
prototyping, so that
means I do a lot of
educational design
and working on
designing experiences
as well as actually building
and making things with my hands.
What I would really
like to solve for
is creating a
global culture that
supports building
confidence in young women
so that they can choose
whether they want
to be artists or scientists
or some combination thereof,
and they feel like that is
something that is open to them
to decide for themselves.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: My
name is Gabriella Levine.
I'm a Hardware Engineer
at Google X. I'm
on a team called
Rapid Evaluation,
and our goal is to prototype
new possible Moonshot
Solutions for Google X.
And the type of work I do
is hardware prototyping
a lot with electronics
and fabrication, and
my passion is in robots
that fly, that walk, that swim.
And I've found a lot
of sort of importance
through communities that I've
learned with, both online
and in person and shared
collaboration makerspaces,
so what I want to solve for
is developing tools that could
give people access
for empowerment
to build things that more
efficiently create automation
and environmental
cleanup, but also
considering design
and experience.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
No big deal, right?
So a really cool side
note, Gabriella was also
one of the I/O
speakers that we had
this past for Women Techmakers,
and there's a great video
online about her talk.
I really recommend
you check it out.
So we're saying some words
that maybe not everyone
is familiar with.
Can I hear a little
bit from one or two
of you, what is prototyping?
Like, we've said that a
couple different times.
KATE STIRR: I can answer
that, because I used it
in two different contexts.
I think for me,
prototyping is really
kind of a mindset of try
it, change it, try it again
where you're working
through ideas quickly
but leaving room for reflection
in between so that you can sort
of-- like, the name of
Gabriella's team at Google
is Rapid Evaluation, and I think
that's a big part of the ethos
of prototyping is being
able to quickly decide
what's working,
what's not working,
and then to iterate on
that and try the next step.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
That sounds right.
So when you're prototyping,
what are the materials
you're working with?
So when I think of prototyping,
I do paper prototyping a lot.
Or we call them
low-res materials.
That's a fancy name for
construction paper and pipe
cleaners.
So I use a lot of low-res
materials when I prototype.
What kind of materials
are you using with
to solve for the projects
that you're working on?
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Really
all kinds of things.
I know working on
the self-driving car,
a lot of my prototypes are about
things users would work with.
And so one of my
first prototypes
that I made when
I was on the team
was it was a cardboard box that
I know made a layout of buttons
on and sat with a user and I
was like, how's this layout?
And then change it a bit.
So it can be things as simple
as that or things as robust
as 3D printed materials or clay
or any sort of thing like that.
NAHID ALAM: So for
me, prototyping
is-- because of my
background at Intel,
I first jumped into
a microprocessor.
So my initial stuff
were basically
Arduinos and a bunch of
sensors, things like that.
And over time, it kind
of moved to like, OK,
you have a crazy wiring
Arduino or Raspberry
Pi or any other computer
things you have in front.
Now, how do you cover it?
So then you move to 3D
printing or the laser cutter.
Things like that
I use regularly.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: I guess
for me my ideal prototyping
is similar to yours where it's
Arduinos, Raspberry Pis, wires,
sensors, but often what I find
might be quicker than just
jumping to do the tools I love
to use is actually to say--
and this is more of
sometimes specific
to a certain application--
to say, well, could I use,
I don't know, paper or pipe
cleaners or low-res materials
to get a first pass to see if a
product that I'm thinking about
might even be valuable.
So do something that might
involve other people and actors
and paper, if that could
be done in 15 minutes,
and then hopefully jump
to the tools I love,
which is hot glue
and electronics.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah, I
feel like I'm a hot glue pro.
I used to go to the
Children's Discovery Museum
a lot in San Jose
when I was younger,
and my mom would
volunteer there.
And so I feel like that was the
beginning of my expert level
glue gunning that I
am now really good at.
We're talking about
rapid innovation,
and I guess we're
suggesting that prototyping
leads to rapid innovation.
What is your favorite
project that you've ever
worked on where you had
a prototype that really
landed and worked out and lead
to something really incredible?
NAHID ALAM: I guess I would
talk about my current project,
really, but other
than that, when
I was pretty early in
prototyping and building
electronics-- tangible,
physical products outside
of my current
work-- at that time,
I was involved
with a STEM group.
They were teaching
high school girls
have to build projects
with tools that
were available at that time.
So one of my favorite
projects, the goal
was to teach girls, high
school girls in a wash-up
how to build a robot.
So I was in a team which
they were basically like, OK,
on the wash-up day,
they will do this thing.
So we first try it.
What will the steps be?
What are the things they need?
What are the
components they need?
How do they need to wire it?
What are the codes
they need write?
So that was to build a
robot car, so I worked
with a couple of other people.
So that was a very
interesting project.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: I guess I also
question does rapid prototyping
lead to rapid innovation
at larger scale, because I
sometimes can do things
very fast to prototype
and get a first model
out, but often I
get stuck trying to scale.
And that's something that
I wonder how could we
bring the prototyping to scale.
So to talk about one project,
I started prototyping a snake
robot, just because
I was excited
about snakes and organic
motion through sort
of linear array of servo motors.
Then I realized, OK,
if I keep prototyping
this, what if I share my designs
and see if other people start
to use this for, I don't
know, for sharing back
new code algorithms
or other things
that other people are doing.
So that's one way.
I think using the internet
to share designs and see
what people all over the world
might build and share back
with you might be one
way to actually lead
this quick cycle of prototyping
to get to a potentially
scaled innovation.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So at some point
I want you to talk a little
bit more about the robot.
Gabriella has a really excellent
story about as some things
that didn't always go well.
And maybe that leads
into my next question,
because it begs the question.
We have low-res materials and we
have these incredible projects
that we work on, but things
don't always go well, right?
Like I said, I'm
a glue gun master,
but that doesn't mean
that I don't burn myself
from time to time.
Thankfully I haven't
lost any fingers
in the projects I've worked on.
I'll say that one project that
I'm especially proud of-- it's
not necessarily my
day-to-day role,
but it's the only
time that I can
claim that I'm a rocket
scientist-- was I built
a four-story hand rolled
aluminum rocket ship
that you might have seen on the
Embarcadero in San Francisco.
And that is built with my art
collective called Five Ton
Crane.
And we built it to engage
people in citizen science.
And that went really well.
But there is definitely
some things that went wrong.
Can you guys share a little
bit about something that failed
and that didn't work?
KIMBERLY SHERIFF:
Yeah, definitely.
I feel like 70% of the
things I make fail,
and that 30% is really
where the money is.
Part of being an innovator
or a prototyper or a maker
is really having a thick skin,
because what we do, design,
make, test, repeat, but
that test part is, I think,
often the most critical part
because you can design things,
you can make it, but if you're
not sharing it with users
and getting their
feedback, you're
not going to be able to
improve your designs.
And so I think often
there's a pride aspect there
where you get really
into this design,
and you've worked really,
really hard on it,
but you give it to a user
and they're like, actually,
I don't like this at all.
And you're like, well,
that's unfortunate.
But as a prototyper,
you have to be
able to take that and
take that design you just
worked for hours and
hours and hours on
and just throw it away and start
with something that is going
to be better for the user.
And really I think
checking your pride
and then accepting
that it's going
to take several
iterations to get
to something that's great
is really, really important.
And to expect
failure and to know
that when your prototype fails,
that doesn't mean you failed.
It means that you have
learned something, hopefully,
from that iteration.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
That's a huge point.
And it's not a
Valley cliche, right?
Like, fail fast, fail
often, fail early.
There are definitely
projects I've
worked on for Women Techmakers
where I was so excited,
we were working so
hard on these projects,
and they just
didn't really land.
They just didn't
really work, and it's
like a little piece of my
heart fell on the floor.
But you know what?
It's cool.
We're going to try
something else.
I learned something from
that, and you move on.
So like I said, it's not
really a Valley cliche.
It's something that I think
a lot of us want to live by
and we try to live
by and we encourage
everyone else to fail.
It's a good thing to fill.
Any other good fail stories?
KATE STIRR: At the
Tinkering Studio where
I work at The Exploratorium,
one of the things
that we try to build
into our activity design
is opportunities to fail in a
way that kind of builds you up.
And so lately what we've
been doing in the space
is making Rube Goldberg
machines or chain reactions,
and so visitors of any age
will come into the space
and they'll create a series
of things that happened
one thing after another.
Maybe a block falls and then
a ball rolls down a ramp
and hits a lever that causes
a pulley to fall off the table
and move a car.
And so there's all of these
moments along the way where
something could go wrong.
As kids are working
on these projects,
they become very invested
in making it succeed,
but almost 100% of
the time there's
one elephant--
element-- elephant?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: That'd be
the best Rube Goldberg machine.
If there's an elephant as a
part of it, it'd be amazing.
KATE STIRR: We have
a squirrel, actually.
Anyway, it's a crazy place.
But there is usually one element
that's not going to work,
and so that is this experience
of try it, change it, try
it again prototyping
over and over again,
within this very safe context.
It doesn't really matter whether
your chain reaction works
or not, it's the experience of
having that iterative process
that builds confidence
and says, well, I
got this one section to work.
And if I had, like,
five more hours,
I could probably get
the rest to work.
But I think that
knowing your limitations
and figuring out what is
possible within the context
that I'm in right now
and evaluating yourself
on that stage rather than
zooming out and evaluating
yourself in kind of a context
the isn't right for what you're
actually trying to
accomplish in the moment
is something that I really
have experienced in my own life
and that I'm trying to promote
in visitors and learners
at The Exploratorium.
NAHID ALAM: I guess
one thing I'll say
is maybe like, really,
disaster doesn't
have any condoms, right?
So if something doesn't work,
you know that it doesn't work.
So it's kind of
like you're crossing
out one of the unknown unknowns
so that you can try out
other parts.
So one of my personal
stories that I
will share is not really
related to prototyping,
but when I was
about six years old,
I looked at a
sewing needle and I
was looking at an electric
socket, and I really thought,
these two will fit really well.
And I put that there.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Now,
you learned something.
Right?
That's important.
KATE STIRR: That doesn't
sound like a failure.
That sounds like a
science experiment.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah, it's
actually a really beautiful
thing that-- I brought
up my mom already
a couple of times-- I
remember one time in a science
experiment I was supposed to
be building a rhinoceros out
of Styrofoam and papier mache.
And my mom thought
that, well, you know,
I needed to take it to
school the next day--
and I wonder if she
remembers this--
but she stuck it in the
oven because she thought
that would make it dry faster.
And it turned into just a sad
mess, and we had to rebuild it.
It was a really nice
thought, and hey, mom.
So you mentioned,
Kate, a little bit
about being hard on yourself.
I find that that's something
that a lot of us as makers,
as creators, as innovators,
we're hard on ourselves.
Like, I think maybe even people
around us are hard on us,
and I think it's because not
that we're perfectionists,
but we just want to
do an incredible job.
And so I want to ask the panel
when you're hard on yourself,
and you realize that that might
be a barrier to you excelling
and going forward, how
do you counteract that?
Or do you have people in
your lives or a mantra
or a method that helps
you take off that baggage,
take off that stuff,
and just keep going?
KATE STIRR: Well,
Gabriella and I
were actually kind of talking
about this before we came up
on stage and just thinking
about when you're not
confident in yourself, how
do you find that confidence?
Does it come from someone else?
I guess I'm kind of
restating your question,
but that's something I think
about for myself a lot.
And so for me, one
thing that helps
is to try to challenge
myself in a different context
and to kind of go through
the things in my life
that I am doing really
well or that I've taken
on these other challenges.
Like, maybe it's
running a marathon
or climbing a challenging
route at the climbing gym
or making a fantastic
gourmet meal or something,
and ticking off those successes
and then reminding myself
that I'm a much bigger person
and fuller person than what
I'm doing in my job.
And so even if a
prototype or some hardware
is not mechanically working
the way that I want it to,
I think having those
other successes
in other parts of
my life remind me
of that I have
this sticking power
and can really push through
and accomplish things,
even when they're challenging.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Yeah.
So I've been at Google now
for a little over a year,
and when I joined the team,
I was straight out of college
and I walked in my
first day, found out
we were making a car, which I
didn't know previous to that--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Little project.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF:
Just a small thing.
And walked in and
was meeting the team,
and I was the only female
mechanical engineer
and still am on the
self-driving car team.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
We'll fix that.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Yeah.
We're working on it.
And that was incredibly
intimidating.
I was in a room with all
of these really, really
impressive engineers.
People who have just
really amazing backgrounds.
Like, did you mean to hire me?
Are you sure?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: That's
a common thing at Google,
actually.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Yeah.
No, it is.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: People will
get their badge and be like,
are you sure?
My name's really on the list?
It happens.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
But you belong here.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Yeah.
No, and [? Ani ?] was talking
about how she felt miserable
and really unqualified in a new
team for the first six months,
and I feel like I had a
really similar experience.
And the way I really gained
confidence was, similar to what
Kate was saying, was just
challenging yourself and really
getting more and more
experience has really
helped me build
confidence and helped
me to get feedback from my
peers that I'm doing a good job.
And that has
definitely improved,
but I definitely think
in the beginning,
my confidence was an
issue, and I'm really
happy that it's improved since.
But I was very timid to
take on those challenges
in the beginning.
Luckily that's not
the case anymore.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
So a good friend of mine,
Elena, she's a Googler.
I wish she was here for
you all to meet her.
We're going to be sharing her
story on the Women Techmakers
YouTube channel in the
next couple of days,
and I'll Tweet it out to
you guys so you see it.
One of the coolest
things about her talk
is she actually
has a Gmail filter,
and so any time anyone
sends or anything
like a thank you or great
job on that project,
she has an Awesome folder.
And so every day, if
she's having a hard day,
she goes to that filter and
she just sees all the praise.
Because when you're having a
hard day, when your shit is not
going right, your project
is not working out,
she has a whole
set of emails that
reminds her how great she is.
And I actually have
a gratitude journal
that I write in all the time.
And when I'm having a rough day,
I go back over the past year
and I just laugh.
That one time when I saw
like a humpback whale spy hop
and I got to touch its nose.
Little things in
life that remind you
that you are not your work.
Your work is
something that you do.
I'm thankful that I get to
bring my passion into my work,
but I can check
out if I need to.
And I think that's a
really important part
of managing-- I
don't want to bring
in too much of the
work/life balance--
but managing some of that
stress that can pop up
in the work environment.
So we have a few
more minutes before I
want to take some
question and answers.
A theme that I've seen pop
up in some conversations
today is around
mentorship and people
that brought you into wanting
to be a prototyper or a maker.
Can you share the
people that inspired you
so in that the room can also
be inspired by those people?
NAHID ALAM: Surely.
The overall maker community,
they were really welcoming,
so that was really
the inspiration.
Like when I got started
with prototyping,
that was one thing.
And then when I was at
Intel, I had a mentor
who was a VIP at
Intel Labs, so he
was a great inspiration in
giving me all the tools he
has in his home.
Like, hey, you take
it and do stuff.
So that was great
[INAUDIBLE] time.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
We're all like nodding.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Yeah.
So for me, I feel like
my-- when you join Google,
you get assigned a mentor--
but for me, my real mentors
came from the people
I was sitting around
and the people I started
working on projects with.
I came in and a
lot of people were
really overwhelmed
with the work they had,
and so I took on some
of those projects.
And those people became
really natural mentors for me.
One of the people I really
look up to the most in my team
is Jaime Waydo, and she-- if you
don't know anything about Jaime
Waydo, you should Google her.
She's an incredibly
impressive woman.
She worked on the Mars
Rover, and now she
is the Systems Lead for the
self-driving car project.
And she's just such a
bubbly and powerful woman
that I luckily get to work
a few feet from and get
inspired by every day.
So I'm incredibly fortunate
to have her in my work group.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: For me it's
been more of a community,
like you said, than
one particular person.
There are a few
people I can mention.
For example, one man,
his name is Tom Igoe,
he's one of the
founders of Arduino
and he was a professor
of mine and just super
supportive and nonjudgmental
of my stupid and crazy ideas
and my mistakes
and failures when
I came to him with
really silly things that
failed because I didn't
take something into account.
But was, yeah, supportive both
technically and conceptually.
But I found more of a
community of sort of mentors
through online forums
of makers and designers,
including Adafruit, she was
on one of the videos that
played earlier.
And Limor Fried runs
an open source hardware
company called Adafruit.
SparkFun I often
post on the forum.
And many people respond
back to questions,
somebody who's an avid
electrical engineer by trade
for many years,
responds to a question
not in a way that makes me
feel like stupid for asking it,
but helpful and uplifting
even if my question might
be something that
has a trivial answer.
Instructables is a website
that I post projects onto,
and then people start
talking through the forum.
But I can also
find answers there.
So it's been online communities
where various people sometimes
keep responding, and I
find particular mentors
through that, but it's
this whole community
and ecosystem that has led
me to find people in general
to use as mentors.
KATE STIRR: My mentor experience
that really stands out
for me was when I was in
college, I was an art major
and I had been doing
a lot of drawing,
2D work, very traditional,
classical art work.
But it was getting towards the
end of my college experience,
and I had to do a thesis
project and I thought, oh, you
know what, I think I've got a
handle on this drawing stuff.
I'm going to do ceramics.
And I'm going to
learn everything there
is to learn about ceramics.
And so then I was kind of
doing that for about a year.
And then I was
like, what I really
want to do is build a boat.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Like a ceramic boat?
KATE STIRR: Well, I did
make some ceramic boats,
but I really wanted to make a
full-sized cedar strip canoe.
And I had never used wood tools.
I had never done any
woodworking except
to make canvases
using a chop saw.
And so the mentor that
really kind of gave me wings
was the sculpture
professor at Lewis & Clark,
where I went to
school in Portland.
And he kind of gave me
keys to the wood shop,
and he showed me how
to use all the tools
and made sure that I
was in a safe space.
Told me to have somebody there
so if I cut my finger off,
somebody could respond.
But it was just that
level of trust in saying,
it's OK that you haven't
done this before.
It's OK that you only have
two months to build this boat.
Go for it.
And that trust is
something that every day I
try to pass on and kind
of hold people up and say,
that's OK that you've
never done this before.
Every time you
try something new,
you're doing
something you haven't
done before and kind of jumping
off a cliff a little bit.
And being able to have
someone there that's saying,
I'll spot you.
It's OK, can be a
really great way
to step back and provide
mentorship without actually
handing someone-- not doing
it for them, but saying,
here's the tools to
go do it yourself.
And I trust you,
and I support you.
So I have always
valued that experience.
It continues to inform me.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
You some of my
favorite words, which
are "trust"-- and one
of my personal mottoes
is that trust is the
only real currency.
And so I think it's one of
the most valuable things you
can have with someone is trust.
Also safety.
I think creating safe
environments for people
to experiment, to innovate,
is also a really cool.
And then sometimes when people
ask me, oh, what is your job?
And I could tell them
the long or short of it,
I like to say that I like to
provide access and give access.
I also like to say I like to
fuel fires, fire starters.
I think that all the women in
this room and around the world
are fire starters.
So if you need
fuel, come ask me.
And so I think that as we
wind down closer to Q&A,
everyone in this room is a
maker, a creator in some way.
And do you have an entry point
or a gateway into making?
So everyone leaves this room and
everyone can go make something,
but how do they
incorporate prototyping
or this idea of rapid
innovation into their work?
KIMBERLY SHERIFF:
I think a lot of it
is just knowing the tools that
are available, because there's
so many resources online
or tools you might already
have that you don't think
of as prototyping materials.
Things like that Amazon
box that just arrived,
that's now prototyping material.
And really, to be a maker,
all you have to do is make,
and so I think that's something
that everybody can do if they
have it in their mind to do it.
NAHID ALAM: I guess if you
want to get started, just
get started.
That's the first thing.
Even five to ten years
back, if somebody
wanted to make something
physical and tangible,
things were kind of secret and
only some special cult group
knows about how to make things.
But those barriers
to entry are kind of
lowering and lowering nowadays.
So you can find a
lot of resources,
as Gabriella mentioned.
SparkFun, Adafruit, and I'm sure
a lot of others are out there.
You can find them.
Make Magazine is one of them.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: I
forgot what I was just
about to jump in with.
I guess I learned a lot
about not how to-- I guess
one really important thing
that I learned was how to learn
or how to Google
for the right thing
or how to use YouTube
to learn anything.
So I feel like that was a
really valuable thing knowing
that most of the information
for making anything,
like from an automation robot
to improved manufacturing,
it's out there on the internet.
Things just need
to be integrated,
but anyone could do it.
It takes a little
patience, but that's
for something of that scale.
I have this particular
anxiety-- especially when I'm
in that position
where I'm saying,
oh, I feel a little
down on myself-- OK,
I better just build something
and stop thinking and just do.
That's been helpful for me
in order to just get started,
just sort of start somewhere.
Take a piece of paper and
fold it into something
or write down the idea.
Yeah, basically just get
over that initial barrier.
And then the barrier to entry
for making physical things
or even doing code prototypes,
it's getting lower and lower.
You can send away for 3D printed
parts at places like Shapeways.
So things are a lot
easier to both find
people online to tell
you how to get started,
but also just to YouTube how
to do something pretty simple.
I use YouTube for that, and
I've learned so much from that.
KATE STIRR: I really
resonate with that idea
of thinking through your hands.
And by just starting to
manipulate a material,
you're getting some other
juices flowing that might not
have already been going.
And also, one thing for me
that keeps me moving forward
is learning new
tools and picking
a tool or a particular
actual mechanical thing,
for example different kinds
of 3D printers or CNC software
and setting up tools
in different ways,
maybe using a lathe or a
manual mill or something
or even just carving something,
I think choosing one tool
and saying, I'm going to master
this tool or I'm going to,
not master it, but just learn
the vocabulary, it opens up.
It's kind of like
speaking a new language,
then you can participate in
this broader conversation
because you have other
elements of vocabulary or tools
that you can use
to move forward.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
I really like that.
And on the YouTube tip,
so a couple of days
ago, the YouTube team launched
a campaign called Dear Me.
Has anyone in this room
seen the Dear Me video yet?
Nice.
One, two, three, great, four.
So by the end of this day,
I would love for all of you
to consider to create
a Dear Me video.
And a Dear Me video--
it's the hashtag dearme--
and it's the idea of what would
you tell your younger self.
And knowing that
many young women,
especially when I was
rebellious and angry
and had body issues when
I was 12, 13-- I mean,
I still kind of have body
issues-- you're not always
the most confident in
yourself when you're younger,
and you're awesome.
You're totally cool
just as you are.
And so these Dear
Me videos are videos
that we encourage
everyone around the world
to share a message
to your younger self.
And Susan Wojcicki,
who's the CEO of YouTube,
just launched hers on the
Women Techmakers channel.
Pavni Diwanji, I was working
on hers with her yesterday.
And so I encourage
everyone to think
of submitting a Dear Me video.
But to that point, what would
you tell your younger self?
The 13-year-old you?
To stay on the path or diverge
or what would you share?
GABRIELLA LEVINE: Well, I
guess I didn't say on path.
So I'd say kudos for that.
But also--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: What
was the original path?
It's OK if you
don't want to share.
GABRIELLA LEVINE:
Classical piano,
cancer research in a biomedical
lab, and then crazy from there.
It was sort of eventually just
the bio and then lab work,
medical school, and at that
point, that didn't happen.
So I say that's a good
thing to follow through
with being OK with-- well, I do
remember being quite confused
for a while saying, I'm not
finding passion in the work
that I know how
to do technically.
I want to do some creative but
also technical, what do I do?
And I'd say, at that
point, relax a little
and try a few things out.
And I guess one thing
that I would say
is don't only do things rapidly.
Maybe slow down and be a little
more introspective sometimes.
And that's particular to me.
But I guess do a
balance of not being
fearful to stray off path,
because so many of us,
for example, at Google, come
from crazy backgrounds that
are winding and end up doing
something that you could
start developing later in life.
So let's say you're
30 or 20, 30 and want
to become an
electrical engineer.
It's not impossible.
So many things aren't impossible
to take nontraditional routes
to get to a place of expertise.
So don't be scared
to just try and fail.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yep.
KATE STIRR: I would
tell my younger self,
and I try to tell
myself on a daily basis,
that it's OK to ask for help.
I think that as a woman
coming into a field
of mechanical prototyping
and hardware prototyping,
there is a lot of
stuff in my head
about I have to be able
to do this all on my own.
I have to just focus and
not ask anyone for help.
I'm going to just go
YouTube that thing,
and I'm not going to communicate
with the people sitting
right next to me and
show that vulnerability
and say I don't know.
Can you show me.
And I think that ultimately
I need to remind myself
that it's OK to not know
everything all the time,
and that the way that I'm going
to move forward as a learner
is by using the
resources around me.
Sometimes that's YouTube,
but a lot of the time,
I love having a person-to-person
interaction of someone
showing me how to
use a new tool,
and then I can go ahead and turn
around and teach someone else
how to use that tool and
reinforce my own skills.
So asking for help
and knowing that I
don't have to be the holder
of all the information all
at once.
Part of my goal for myself
is to be a lifelong learner
and to constantly be
adding to my skill base,
and the only way that I'm
going to be able to do that
is to reach out and ask
other people around me.
NAHID ALAM: I think what
I would say to my younger
self is be more fearless.
My experience is kind of the
reverse of what Gabriella said.
There were a lot of times when
I was not sure what to do,
and I basically sat
down like "The Thinker".
I would do nothing.
So I think I should have
done more at the time
and been more fearless
and not thinking too much
of what's going to happen next.
So just do it kind of mentality.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF:
I think for me I
would really love to tell
13-year-old Kimberly what
an engineer is.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
That's a good thought.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Yeah.
I definitely had no idea
what that meant until maybe
my freshman year of college.
And I feel like
you go to a doctor,
you know what a doctor does.
You have teachers,
you know what they do.
You've seen television shows
with politicians or lawyers
or things like that.
So you know what all of
these professions are,
and so 13-year-old
Kimberly was going
to be the President
of the United States
and had zero interest in math.
And I feel like if I
had known at that time
what an engineer does and that
you make things for people,
I would have probably pursued
that much sooner than I did.
And I feel like this
maker culture that we're
trying to encourage and
develop is a really great thing
for education,
because it's a way
to explain to young kids who
might not have access or role
models that are engineers
or technical people what
it is to be an engineer
or developer or designer
kind of thing.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: I
agree with that, also.
Because I remember
having the opportunity
to take a computer science
class or health class,
and for some reason,
I chose health class.
It didn't resonate, so
I started programming
at a much later age.
And I wish I had more skills,
but I didn't know what it was.
So, yeah, if somebody put
a little tool in my hand
and said, go play with this.
Or go program on one
particular language,
my mind might have been
blown 15 years ago.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: When I think
of my path, it's super winding.
I'm mean, college jobs are
college jobs in some ways.
I worked in a deli, I
worked at Starbucks,
I've helped teach English
to younger children who
didn't know English, I've
worked in community management
for a really long
time, I used to throw
illegal underground raves.
And I ended up here.
My background is in
building communities.
I've done that for
the past 10 years.
And so I always
knew that I wanted
to do something for women,
and actually, young people.
And so I got to the
technology industry,
and I was like, why technology?
I thought the only way I
could solve for the world was
to work for a nonprofit.
That's what I thought.
And so when I landed
here, and I started
to see just how things
started to come together,
it was like the windy path
started to make sense.
But I didn't set
out thinking that.
I wanted to be a high school
history teacher so bad.
That was my job.
I was set.
And then finally,
when it came down
to getting the certification,
my dad and I agreed.
Because he was like,
you have too much energy
to just stay put.
So go out and explore the world.
And I'm so glad my dad and
I talked about doing that,
because it was the best thing
that ever happened to me.
So thank you to our panelists.
I want to be able to open
the floor to Q&A. We've
talked about a lot.
We've talked about what
prototyping is, what innovation
is, what tools we use, what
tools we encourage you to use
to incorporate into your work
as a developer or as a designer,
as an entrepreneur.
And I'm sure you have questions,
and we love passing the mic.
So we're going to have
some mic runners that
are going to be running around
the room with some mics.
So if you raise your hand,
we'll happily answer questions
for the next 15 minutes or so.
Mic runners, mic
runners, where they at?
Nice.
They'll just kind
of pick at random.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a Software
Engineer at Cisco.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Welcome.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question about prototyping.
So when you design or when
you prototype something,
it's a new product of technology
which doesn't have any existing
customer base.
What are things to keep in
mind or take into consideration
to make sure that your product
gets a customer buy-in?
NAHID ALAM: So I think
the first question to ask
is, is it solving any problem?
Not just because I'm an
engineer and I can make things,
so I make things.
So the first question is,
is it solving any problem?
Maybe you're solving a problem
for a working, professional
woman, go talk to them.
Hey, I'm thinking of this.
Talk to your friends.
Talk to a few more people,
maybe five, ten people, and say,
hey, I'm thinking of this.
Would you buy this?
So that kind of gives you
sort of an early validation.
And then maybe you can do
prototyping and show them.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So knowing the user.
NAHID ALAM: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
It's really important
before you get started.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: Yeah.
And there are
various ways to say--
I mean, there could be a
different reason why you're
prototyping a product or a
tool, and it could, oh, I just
have inspiration to build this.
OK, that's OK.
But what if you are
trying to say, well, where
might it fit in in the world?
Then you could
say, OK, what does
it look like when it gets
to the customer's hand,
and then sort of
step back from there.
Or do initial research.
Talking to people
is such a great way
of knowing your user that
way, and then saying, well,
maybe this product or this thing
that I was going to prototype
could be prototyped
totally differently.
And then be open to drop that.
It's sort of a
solution-based approach.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: One of
my favorite things, IDEO,
they're great,
they have something
called-- they used to call it
the Human-Centered Design Kit.
I think they just call
it the Design Kit now.
I'd recommend checking it out.
It's a way for you to approach
solving a problem from a user's
perspective.
And also I think
being able to observe
the world in a way
as a problem solver
and to develop really
interesting solutions
from that.
So Design Kit from IDEO is
a cool free online resource.
Anybody else?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I also work for Cisco.
I'm a systems engineer
working on automation.
Kate, I loved that you
mentioned climbing,
because I think it's a
great activity for engineers
and women.
But my question is I'm
wondering if each of you
could speak to your
strengths as a woman that
make you good at your job.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: I
guess I can start.
I think one of my
biggest strengths
and what makes me really
good at the team I'm on
is my ability to
iterate so quickly.
So the work I do
is very fast-paced.
We're trying to get these
self-driving cars to users
as quickly as possible,
and so a lot of that
is trying to figure out
what's best for the user.
And so I work a lot with
user experience teams
and make a design, they test it.
Make a design, they test it.
And I could do three
of these things in one
week and get them all made
and prototyped and ready.
And so I think for me, that's
probably my biggest strength.
But to counter that, I think
sometimes one of my biggest
weaknesses is, because
we're moving so quickly,
and speaking to
Gabriella's point,
is sometimes I think I can
move a little too quickly
and miss some of the
details that if I had spent
just a little more
time in this iteration,
we might not have needed
two more kind of thing.
So there's a balance there.
NAHID ALAM: I think
my biggest strength
is I love to make
physical, tangible things.
And even though it's much
harder to build and deliver
those products in
the market, I love it
so much that I'm ready
to go through that pain.
I think that's my
biggest strength.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: For me I think
one of my biggest strengths
is being aware of and gauging
the temperature of other folks
on the team and synthesizing
where everyone's at.
Trying to kind of gauge what's
happening with each member
in solving a particular
problem and how can I
help them communicate
that to each other
and how can I share out
with the broader group what
our team is thinking.
And I think that, for me, I
really get a lot of energy
from having diverse
opinions and trying
to reconcile those
opinions in a way that
moves the whole team forward.
GABRIELLA LEVINE:
You said what's
your strength as a woman.
I was trying to think is
that different than just
strength in general?
I'm not sure if it is.
Maybe it is.
One thing that I think is
a strength is that I hear,
statistically, women
are less apt to not
be afraid of trying something
that they don't know.
Or if somebody says,
could you do this?
Be like, yes, I could do this.
I have no idea how to do this.
But I'll figure it out,
and figure out also
how to delegate the things
I don't know to other people
and manage that aspect
while also learning
a lot of new tools and figuring
out a quick way to do that.
Yeah.
Learn to do something
myself or delegate it out.
Yeah, I guess that's one.
I don't know.
I think I've worked
in a lot of jobs
with mostly men, some of
them have had physical labor.
Being physically strong has
made me feel like, OK, I'm
going to impress them by being
able to do as many pull-ups
as them.
But that, I think, is not
particular to this job.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: What
Gabriella is also not
sharing with you is she's
an emergency firefighter,
so that's why she's
doing pull-ups
in the forest fighting fires.
That's what she's
done in a past life.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: But sometimes
I sneak it into the lab
just so people know also
that it's not like women
are different and weak.
Don't be hindered
by expectations.
So that I guess
is something that
like I hope makes people's
stereotypes blown.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So there's some teams.
So Women Techmakers
is not just me.
I don't create this
in a silo, there
are hundreds of people
around the company that make
Women Techmakers what it is.
They're the people
that are wearing
the green shirts and
the blue shirts today,
and I'm not speaking directly
to all of them right now,
but some of the women that
contribute 20% of their time
to working on Women Techmakers,
I'll see their contributions.
And this is a lesson
for some of them--
and you might know
who I'm talking
to you-- some of my
contributors will
share some very simple
sentence of what
they did to their managers.
Like, I launched a program.
But I'm like, wait, I'll
look at their update,
and I'm like, you launched it
to a hundred people in a week.
And you killed it.
And what I find is that not
only my contributors to Women
Techmakers, but
women in general,
don't sell themselves enough.
You have so many strengths.
You do such incredible
work, and for some reason
that gets lost at
the opportunity
to report out about
what you're doing.
And an old time Googler
told me that reporting out
about your work inside
the company, and even
inside and outside the
company, is 50% of your job.
Sharing out about you.
And so I really encourage
you, yes, they're strengths,
now communicate
them in your jobs.
Communicate them online.
Write blog posts about
how bad ass you are.
That's important.
Anyways, more questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm [INAUDIBLE],
also from Cisco.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Wow.
This is a Cisco dominated room.
This is great.
AUDIENCE: So we talked
a lot about prototyping
and you also discussed how
70% of the time it may fail.
So when you decide
to start or do
a prototype for your
project, be it your work
or your personal project,
what are the key factors
that you should consider
before starting it in order
to go in the right direction?
You never know,
it may still fail,
but then that will help
you prevent failure
in some way in the future.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: So I think
the really important things
to know going in
are who is my user,
if there is a user, what's
the purpose of this thing.
If you really understand the
requirements of your project
or of your thing, it'll help
you a lot in the design.
And if you don't
know those things,
perhaps it's a user
interface type thing,
and you don't know
the requirements yet,
it's often best to get a really,
really quick prototype out.
It doesn't need to be pretty,
but a really, really quick one
that you can then get
into users' hands.
And then from that
feedback, make more
of a detailed real-life model.
NAHID ALAM: Yeah.
I think, as Kim mentioned,
that if you really
know what the function of the
prototype you are going to make
is, then it becomes easier.
And then if you are obviously
doing something physical,
then there are some components
and sensors and things
like that that are involved.
So as soon as you know
what you are going to make,
if you just order them online,
it will reach you in five days.
So you can do yourself a favor
by ordering early, I guess.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Cool.
Any more questions
from Cisco people?
No, I'm just kidding.
From anyone?
I love it.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
Excuse me.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: I
don't know where you are.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Oh, over here.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Oh, OK.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
We've got to add more
light to this side of the room.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
My question is
about how you ensure
that your customer,
the people, the public,
the trust your product.
Especially I've
always been interested
in self-driving
autonomous vehicles--
I would love to be
part of it in any way--
how do you know that your
grandmother will trust
your product to be driven in?
Because they have to trust
it with their life, right?
Or how that kayak that
Kate built-- obviously
you can test it
yourself, and a kayak
is less dangerous, because you
probably can get out safely.
How do you do safety
trusting in your prototype?
KIMBERLY SHERIFF: Well, first,
for the self-driving car,
safety has been a
huge priority for us.
And we're really going
above and beyond standards
to make sure this vehicle
will be safe for the public.
Everything is redundant,
and we've put a lot of time
into testing this for safety.
And so I think that in itself
will build public trust for it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, absolutely.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: Yeah.
So you could have safety
built-in and redundant,
but people not feel safe
just because they don't
know about it and trust it.
So I think that's
often a question where
you bring some sort of
user experience design
and talk to people.
What makes you feel trust
about being in a car that
might drive itself?
Sometimes I could consider
asking a question like that
and having a brainstorm
session about what
might be ways to impose trust
on people in a vehicle that
might not be typical.
Do they want to feel like
they have control to take over
or not and just try
things out on people.
So that's something that
I'm dealing with a lot
when thinking of a
new crazy product that
might be cool to make.
Thinking of will that even
fly, because will people
be OK trying something?
If so, how do you make
something be comfortable
for the public, and
thinking about, again,
knowing your user.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I
would say some common tools
when we're trying to think of
those that Gabriella touched on
is a how might we statement.
So it's a part of that
understanding the user design
and doing research.
So I would encourage
you to go back
to your team, if you're building
something for the public,
and sit down with
your team and just
be like, how might we
create trust in our product?
Because then you're not starting
from a statement or an opinion.
You're just opening
it up to the room.
How might we solve
for something,
and that allows everyone's
voice to just come out and get
creative.
Also, a really cool
tool when you're
trying to do this constructive
brainstorming of how you might
create trust or how you
might create security
is learning to say
"yes, and" to people.
This is an improv technique.
For the theater
people in the room,
you know what I'm talking about.
I think we skip to saying no and
sharing an opinion too quickly
and shooting down
ideas-- we as humans.
So the more that we
can say "yes, and",
you're going to create a
radically more interesting
experience and solution if
you can add to people's ideas
instead of shooting them down.
Any other questions?
Middle of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I'm Tanya.
And thanks to Google
and Women in Technology
for having us over here.
Talking about
making and creating,
I can totally relate
to it, because I
work at a startup in San
Francisco named Brit + Co,
I'm not sure if
you've heard of it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
Of course.
AUDIENCE: So our tag
line is Live Creatively.
So it's like an
online community where
you can reach other people,
have women homemakers totally
create things.
So my question to
you would be that we
have so many ideas in our
minds and so many things to do.
You have a 9:00 to 5:00 job,
you want to work out in the gym,
you want to go home and
create something, cook food.
So how do you go
about time management?
How do you set your priorities?
GABRIELLA LEVINE: It's hard.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: There's
so many things to do.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: Kate and
I were talking about this
this morning.
Sometimes some
things come up where
you're doing a
particular project that
makes everything else go away.
Is that OK?
For some people,
it might not be.
But one thing for me, when
we're talking about making
and how does everybody make
something become a DIY,
something that's
helped me is to say,
OK, I know I can't do this
five days a week after work
for ten hours or five hours.
What if I just
start really simply.
I'm going to block
out two hours of time,
do something really simple, like
learn some tool or something
that I've always
wanted to do, like fix
the drain in my bathtub, instead
of calling someone, let me try
and do this myself
because it might
feel good to actually do it.
Look online, how do you fix
the drain in the bathtub.
And just to do something
that's small barriers
to entry, small goals.
And then for me, it
incites this passion
that allows me to build
that more into my schedule.
So it's just starting off
with small increments,
and then, if you
like that, it's been
more easy for me to say, no, I
can't go get a drink tonight.
I have this excitement to finish
this robot snake prototype.
KIMBERLY SHERIFF:
For me, I think
what helps is making a
date with someone else
to work on something.
And maybe we're going to work
on our own things side-by-side.
Some friends have
started a Work Wednesday
where they have a
gallery space and machine
shop in a warehouse in Oakland.
And so every couple
Wednesdays, we'll
all get together and work
together in the same space,
but on our own projects.
And I love that
they started this,
because it holds me accountable
to come make something
and to schedule that art making
that I might not prioritize
above doing my job and
getting my work done
and having a relationship
and making good food
and getting exercise
and all of those things.
You have to block it
off and hold yourself
accountable to someone else.
It helps me to not just
be accountable to myself,
but to be accountable
to other people
are to ask for help
on a project where
I need to learn a new
skill from someone else.
So I'm going to set a
date with them where
they're going to come over,
I'm going to cook them dinner,
and then they're going to help
me with the Arduino project.
That's how I make art.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So we
have just a few seconds left,
and I actually want to use
those few last seconds to give
a huge round of applause
for our awesome panelists.